yeah you have to you have to observe
better so we're going to start going
from a kihon to more of an application
Okay so
right and we have shihon nage
coming out
we're gonna take the
Escape okay so this one
out here then step into the two on one
clear the line
he's going that way
[Music]
he's going this way
angle deflection
One Way angle deviation the other way
okay let's go
okay so you you need that uh Yin space
right it could be it pulls that's going
to begin energy
okay
um so he pulls in you have uh cook your
hole see
but we're gonna do it from the arm who's
pulling and we'll come in and we'll use
the arm to do the top topsy-turvy effect
so this
in the same way
conceptually if you can't enter that far
you can just pick up the leg pick up the
leg with the knee
sweep the leg this way
but keep this aren't going
and look for the end
so as he's going maybe it's a wall maybe
he stopped he stopped okay and that's
gonna be but look at his base that's
gonna be where I use it okay
the other way you can generate a yet
movement is let's say he's going young
you see
so I'm just gonna move out of the way he
goes young and I shaved
okay so I'm here maybe he pulls right
now he's going young and I shake
so
we'll be here in the camera okay
stay here
's Where We Are
okay
as he starts to push on me I shave this
way
so imagine our bodies here he goes to
push and move out a little bit
I like all the arm as he pushes and I
take the head
oh here he pushes
[Music]
starting position when he pulls I just
move in with it
but our ego instinct is when he pulls a
brace and then I'll try to go okay
so I'm stuck to him he goes to pull and
I'm moving in with that
he goes to pull and I'm beginning with
that
you should feel it before anyone else
can see it because he's gonna tense his
muscles and you're already moving
you're already moving
watch your instinct
and then you go
so it's where he goes
[Music]
it's when he goes
foreign
okay
and so here you can you can he he goes
to push you can see you have GG now
but we're going to do it from the two on
one
again as he pushes don't brace
you should feel it he goes to push and
that's your Technique
okay
he comes around his circle is going that
way you see so let's put it on the clock
so you can see
so you go clockwise
and we usually go inside this circle
going the other way okay
so all of your ratio
techniques are
like that
the ones where we're coming in okay so
we're gonna use that second
so I go to the two on one because I
drive that gets most people to push
that's when I yield against his bow
honestly he's going to come in you see
well that's that same Circle he's going
around me I'm going to come inside his
Circle
that's right
inside his Circle
I don't care if you hold the arm right
now this work the pattern
right here
there's obviously the same timing so if
he pushes if I go like that this
technique doesn't work it's when he
pushes that's when this works
same way as when he pulls that's when
all those work it's not he pulls resist
and then go so same thing here he pushes
a yield
when he goes to stand up that's when I
go I can't be standing then I go
we're changing
places
okay let's go
here's the elbow arm that's the one I
don't want to go up okay so I'll hold
the wrist arm as long as I need to to
get over here
you can still hold it if you want you
can still hold it but you don't need it
you can also come to the legs here on
the on the front
right you do want to go around that
elbow arm
and the way you get around it is with
that same softness
okay let's go so uh let's say
uh I got a gate or he's like trying to
rip my badge off of me
oh do you get it so same same thing so
he he goes to grab oh look you're in the
same thing goes to grab oh you're just
thinking
he goes he does get a grip you're in the
same thing
he's got a clinch you can see he's
charging the clinch and and you're in
the same exactly
you guys see that you go right to the
two on one okay so uh
you can do it on a grab a clamp
you could do it on the ground just push
you could do it on the clintonship tab
boom and then start any of those
techniques that we went over okay all
right let's go
[Music]
foreign
and then I I think it's okay to go
through a phase where
kind of slowing the technique down
through contestation
you know just a little bit and then you
do some yields
that's okay that's like a growing phase
as long as you keep training and again
we all know what that means right four
to six hours a day listen to your
teacher do all the other supplemental
trainings you'll get through that phase
but if you're pushing pushing pushing
forcing forcing Force that's a different
face do you understand so I'll describe
if you guys know some of you are looking
at me right here okay so maybe I go to
push and he pushes that is a that's a
contestation do you see I don't want to
hold it here and try to shove and do
that one maybe my instinct I pulse on
the resistance and then you'll see me
yield
that phase is okay
got it so it's okay
but he's doing whatever and I'm very
soft very soft
okay and I would like for you to try to
lose that little pulse okay so he does
whatever
thank you
[Music]
I couldn't feel the instinct
I feel it in my body
and I'm going to release that like horse
pose
lessons of course toes keep releasing
releasing quotes
and I would rather you do that over the
movement
over the movement
[Music]
always have moved me release get out of
there